[Music]
interesting addition of pft ot on this
monday after week seven because at some
point while we are talking about things
we didn't get to during pft live we're
going to get a phone call yes a phone
call from travis kelsey that's how we
roll chiefs we get phone calls from
travis kelsey and we're going to put him
through and we're going to ask him some
questions it's chiefs packers sunday
night football week eight but
sunday night football week seven eagles
and the cowboys it was a week ago today
that doug peterson made his
non-guarantee guarantee he was on wip
radio in philly he said very
nonchalantly and as part of the
conversation we're gonna win he was
asked by reporters later to talk about
his guarantee he's like what guarantee
well the cat was already out of the bag
he knew he knew that he went too far and
the cowboys players mostly kept their
mouths shut when it was time to go out
there and play they stuck it to the
eagles and i think they found extra
motivation in peterson's comments yeah i
don't think there's any doubt about that
especially when you see some of the
post-game comments from some of the guys
on the cowboys it definitely was uh in
their minds as they took the field and
you know as we've talked about a lot nfl
players look for anything to
get themselves pissed off pumped up
whatever it may be
this is a huge rivalry as is and yeah
they didn't like to hear that you know i
don't think doug peterson is trying to
make any sort of guarantee but he talks
himself into the corner when you just
talk matter-of-factly and say oh we're
going to go down and get a win well i
don't really care if you say guarantee
or not at that point you know the the
newspapers are gonna run with it and of
course the team you're playing is gonna
run with it and uh yeah i wouldn't think
rod marinelli especially on that
defensive side of the ball had his guys
riled up uh for sunday night because of
those comments demarcus lawrence was the
only one who broke from
the rest of his teammates before the
game he said
don't talk about peter shields
shut your ass up and stay on the side
right after the game ezekiel elliott
said honestly we don't give a bleep what
doug peterson says right one of your
favorite words was it the f word
yes yes yes you want me to prepare you
want me to get it out there for
everybody
we don't give a yeah it's not fart let's
just say that it's not it's not that i'm
allowed to say it on ot i know but then
they got to bleep it out
okay it's still a family show right
we're still yes is it a family show i
hope not uh but but the cowboys four and
three coming together and i think they
really like that sense of being under
siege because they they find a way to to
perform at a higher level i think jason
garrett feeling the red-hot poker as you
would say sure it really does snap them
out of it and last year when they beat
the eagles when they were three and five
starting the second half of the season
went to philly on sunday night football
and won that game it sparked a 7-1
finish and the next thing you know a
team that started three and five is in
the final eight yeah they're hoping
there's a similar impact this year
without having to get to three and five
and if they go on a run like that this
year maybe it's gonna be hard to get a
bye week yeah
but they easily can win the division and
then maybe they can make some noise in
the postseason i think they're you know
i'm i'm not giving up on the dallas
cowboys i still think they're one of the
the more talented teams in football and
i think they'll be in this you know
they're going to be in the playoffs
that's what i'm saying i just really
would be shocked you're really not going
out on a limb well i know but you know
it's but i do i just think they're a
playoff quality football team i think
they're a better team than they were
last year yeah they hit a few hiccups
the last few weeks certainly i get that
um but i just look at their offenses
being more creative than years past
their defense is still really good and
the big thing is within that doug
peterson stuff uh and the two guys that
spoke out about it after the game those
were the two guys that needed the
biggest jolts in their game demarcus
lawrence and ezekiel elliott were the
guys that i think we all questioned the
most where the hell are you why aren't
you getting as many yards as you should
why aren't you getting sacks like you
should and uh they they showed up last
night in a big way especially early on
to kind of get the team confident and
get the ball rolling and it was it was
no looking back after that now the
marcus lawrence got his contract in the
offseason yeah so he didn't go through
that same kind of on-the-fly adjustment
think about everything ezekiel had to
process he had the fight of the holdout
right he's in mexico he's trying to hold
firm while the cowboys are trying to
talk him into taking less than what he
wanted he finally gets his deal and then
it's right back to it you don't get a
chance to process these newfound riches
you don't get to figure out what you're
going to do with the money i mean you
trust people to properly take care of it
but it's it's issues it's a lot of
balance all at once and you're trying to
get yourself in shape he didn't have
that burst earlier in the year he had it
last night yeah it was real close i
think that bodes well it does yeah he
needs it i mean because it's not about
you know i don't come away from games
just going watching him on film and i
don't mean to be johnny film guy but i
don't come away going oh he ran for a
hundred yards that's a good day no it's
what's there to be had pass game run
game alike and there was just too many
instances over the last few weeks where
i went ooh like the top three or four
running backs in football would have got
40 yards in that run and ezekiel got 15.
and that's when i start to have an issue
and i start to notice things like that
week after week and one or two times a
game those can be game changing type
plays or runs and when you're not
getting that type of performance out of
the guys you're paying the most and
expect to have those type of
performances usually your team can can
falter and they falter
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports